so this is an omnidirectional treadmill
so this is the only one that's chimeric
commercially available in the UK you're
not Europe and it's built by a company
called Omni affinity based in Sweden and
they've been developing this for the
last ten years for the Special Forces
well they want to take infantryman have
been trained bring them to to the
various divisions and then get them
experiencing different types of
scenarios and this this allows them to
freely move through that space and they
can run a number of configurations and
and scenarios them to test out their
tactics and kind of stuff we're looking
at kind of commercial technology coming
from the games industry particular
interests with the homely deck which was
not really in most people's budgets but
what it allows you to do is move freely
through freely through large virtual
environments and we're interested in
allowing people to experience
transport-related scenarios so it can be
very large places like airports and
train stations and allow people to
navigate through that and understand
what the future might look like
essentially what we have a survive you
might want to step off the on theater
role as though because they allows
you're walking with me so we have to
vibe sensors which track the headset
that's connected to the omni finishes
software which interprets that and
allows your character to move around
unity giving you free movement to walk
around so for example we walk in this
direction the rollers here are powered
individually so as you walk forwards
they get faster so the idea is that you
can then transition through an
environment without having to worry
about a controller you can move freely
and walk up to objects and as you get
more and more experienced you can really
move around at pace so here we're
actually walking into the trees we can
change direction and walk in this
direction over here for example and the
kind of thing within this particular
demo I've been looking at is we're
actually in Milton Keynes well there we
are me in Milton Keynes this is in
virtual Milton Keynes and we replicated
this to allow us to start investigating
some of the interactions between
autonomous vehicles and people so
clearly having large robotic vehicles
driving around
on pavements can be hazardous and has
various paperwork associated with it not
every day is sunny as in in virtual
reality and we can then train people to
work to walk on the Omni deck and just
walk from here to the train station in
VR encountering these autonomous
vehicles and on those vehicles we can
start to change their behavior we can
apply different types of interfaces so
the whole thing could blow pink it could
project a big red dot on the ground or
have various means of communicating via
audio and behavioural changes so similar
to you and I walking down a pavement you
will see somebody in front and if
they're distracted you might give way
and move around them if you're if they
are looking very not very confident they
might decide to change direction and so
on so look at all those subtleties of
interaction and what's the minimum we
need to implement onto autonomous cars
to give the likes of the public you and
i confidence that they have seen me they
will stop they will react and behave in
a natural natural fashion so we can do
all this in virtual reality which is a
huge cost saving and because this is a
simulated environment we can implement
everyone to in any way control all those
factors which is very hard to do if
you're doing user trials in Henery in
the real world we've had three four
hundred people come through the lab this
is actually the upgraded version of the
deck we had previously now the gap is
minimal there's no chances of shoes
catching the edges completely natural is
faster and so on so we've gotten really
good positive interactions people was
jumping on with five minutes they're
naturally walking around we map out a
chaperone boundary which vive and oculus
people be familiar with so as you get
towards the edge of the omni deck you
can see that and we can increase the
speed of the deck so if you're
particularly confident if a large stride
we can increase that speed so you never
reach the edge we're not doing the kind
of things the military were doing where
you can run jump and crawl some of the
videos on the omni affinity and website
will show that and it is capable of that
but somewhat outside of our area of
research so we got some some virtual
circles here well starter to accelerate
and rate of rotate the rollers so if I
walk forward to be able to see the role
as a moving on my feet
I know what people will be thinking
you're watching this there'll be people
out there thinking things like this so
yeah so we've talked Omni affinity about
applications of interest to our our
particular area of transport but they
are branching out from servicing and
military and Special Forces into VR
arcades so they're exploring different
opportunities to create large warehouses
full of these omni decks so that there
can be teams either playing each other
in those waiting those in those
facilities or playing international
teams distributed around the globe so
yeah it's an obvious kind of follow-on
because they've been doing simulations
with ground forces with tanks with
helicopters etc so they're using that
same technology and now bringing it to
the gaming industry what I encourage you
now to shift your head a bit left and
right because then you get something
this is what you would not get with the
traditional defecate one you will get it
done with the next version of the rift
your computer will capture the first
model field and it will capture the
second even field and it will start to
interlace them back together to create a
single frame